hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
applications of pro-calcitonin aided
decision making for antibiotic
stewardship in emergency care
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please follow the process to obtain your
credits by clicking on the continuing
education
credits window i'd like to now welcome
our speaker
larissa may professor of emergency
medicine
and director of emergency department and
outpatient antibiotic stewardship
at the university of california davis
larissa you may now begin your
presentation
great thank you
okay can you see my slides
yes you can wonderful well i'm delighted
to be here and thank you all for
attending
we're going to be talking about
applications of procalcitonin to
improving antibiotic stewardship in
emergency care
the objectives for our talk today are to
discuss procalcitonin as a biomarker
to help distinguish viral versus
bacterial infection to review some of
the literature supporting the role of
pct and promoting antimicrobial
stewardship
and patient outcomes in various clinical
settings particularly focused on the ed
and to discuss some opportunities and
challenges of implementing pct
in emergency care settings
these are my disclosures
so let's focus first on antimicrobial
stewardship
i'm sure most of you are familiar with
the growing problem and public health
threat of antimicrobial resistance
a lot of this is fueled by inappropriate
prescribing of antibiotics in a variety
of healthcare settings
actually the vast majority of
prescribing is for upper respiratory
tract infections that occur in the
outpatient setting
and yet we also know that antimicrobial
resistance causes increased morbidity
mortality and healthcare cost
and therefore there's a great focus on
limiting antimicrobial use that's
inappropriate in the inpatient setting
as well
it's also a patient safety issue as
antibiotics that are unnecessary
can be associated with adverse events
the most pressing of which
is the increasing incidence of
clostridium or clostridium rather
difficile infection
so what about antibiotic stewardship in
the emergency department this really is
an opportunity for us to focus
on the quality of care so what is
antibiotic stewardship it really is
the optimization of antibiotics
so broad spectrum antibiotics are often
appropriate in our setting
for example they are key to the
surviving sepsis campaign and i'll show
some data about how
antimicrobial use and starting it early
can actually improve patient outcomes
we're also measured on some of these
metrics
and so their incentives on hospitals to
comply with them
and finally clinical pathways will often
include
decision making tools that will help
guide antimicrobial choices
what we do know from our setting in the
emergency department is that the choice
that we make
as empiric therapy in the ed is often
continued into the inpatient setting
what is the role of rapid diagnostics
and biomarkers in acute infection
i'm going to discuss some of the
opportunities and challenges to using
these in acute care
the application of potential testing
strategies and really the emphasis on
appropriate integration into the
clinical environment
including assessment of workflows in
various clinical settings the need to
align with clinical operations and
obtain leadership support
and finally really integrating those
tools into antimicrobial stewardship and
patient safety endeavors
there are multiple approaches to
stewardship and improvement of patient
safety
so until recently many hospitals did not
engage or include
ed clinicians in their existing
antimicrobial stewardship planning
committees
however that is rapidly changing
appropriate stewardship requires
multidisciplinary collaboration
and some strategies might include
education although we know that's not
sufficient
for maintaining change guidelines and
clinical pathways
can also be developed that can help
guide clinicians to doing the right
thing
and then finally other strategies such
as peer comparisons and audit and
feedback can also
provide important input into changing
practice
with the advent of the electronic health
record we're moving more towards the
direction of clinical decision support
that can also incorporate some of these
tools and in the ed we have focus on
care
transitions for example patients being
discharged to the hospital or returning
to long-term care facilities
or skilled nursing facilities and then i
highlight here rapid diagnostics and
biomarkers that we'll be spending the
rest of our time
talking about as it is a cornerstone of
the idsa strategy to combat
antimicrobial resistance
we do have some current limitations in
terms of infectious diseases diagnosis
and that is mainly that our clinical
judgment in the emergency department is
often insensitive
and we often do not have diagnostic
technology available in real time
or that technology is not specific or
sensitive enough to provide quick and
accurate data
therefore we have to employ a variety of
strategies to improving antibiotic
selection
ultimately what happens though is this
leads to a conservative management
approach
where patients will get antibiotics
that are often more broad spectrum than
necessary
the benefits of course are offset by the
cost of treatment and potential
complications from unnecessary treatment
or overtreatment
but what does this mean in the real
world what it means in terms of
diagnostics is there's a gap in
translating
promising technologies so we really need
to look at feasibility including those
workflow assessments i talked about
and also knowing that i'm talking
probably mainly to a microbiology
audience we really need to redefine
what rapid means so testing and
stewardship
starts in the emergency department
however our definition of a rapid test
is something that returns in real time
rather than an eight hour test and that
can really be linked to improved patient
outcomes
but implementation is key for example if
we're going to implement a biomarker
that could potentially change practice
in reducing inappropriate antibiotic
therapy
then we need that test to be implemented
in such a way that it fits with our
workflow
and returns in real time rather than
batch testing
the focus also is often on high yield
settings where the use would have had
the greatest impact on outcomes
so for example for procalcitonin
in our et we frequently look at febrile
infants and adults with sepsis
so i'm going to talk a little bit about
sepsis because it is such an important
concern and leads to such mortality in
the united states
so there's an early detection benefit
for sepsis
if we detect sepsis early on in the
course of the patient's illness
the chances for survival improved and
really that has to do with starting
appropriate empiric antibiotic
therapy as quickly as possible and so
you can see the survival rate here
really drops as time goes on and we miss
this diagnosis
there's some other gaps in diagnostics
in sepsis so again here at the top graph
you see
the time to appropriate treatment versus
survival and so that's really
appropriate starting of antimicrobial
therapy
and you can see waiting more than 24
hours results
in less than a 5 chance of survival
the immune system also plays an
important role
in when the deaths from sepsis occur so
early on
for example in a healthy individual with
meningococcemia with a hyperimmune
response you can see many of the deaths
are going to be early
whereas in elderly patients who might
have some chronic comorbidities
and a more localized infection you can
see that the
deaths may occur later and then finally
in the
patients that may have diabetes and some
other comorbidities
who have pneumonia the deaths tend to
occur late
however starting antimicrobials is
really a balancing act
so on the one hand we have overuse of
unnecessary antimicrobials
that lead to downstream individual and
community antimicrobial resistance
the incidence of clostridium difficile
and other toxicities and adverse
outcomes such as anaphylaxis
and other minor complaints such as
diarrhea or yeast infections
and then we have to balance that with
the correct initial choice of empiric
antibiotics
because we know that improves patient
outcomes and reduces death
so here we see an antimicrobial spectrum
of activity
when we look at an infected patient
there's a range of pathogens that can
cause these infections
and we really have to think about
empiric versus definitive therapy
so looking at the baseline we're trying
to figure out what the source of
infection is in a more syndromic
approach
what types of pathogens might be causing
the infection
and looking at community acquired versus
healthcare associated infection
typically we want to start early broad
spectrum empirical therapy for patients
with sepsis within an hour
but really as you can see here with the
diagnostic tools we have we're
very limited in terms of what options we
have
to make the right decision so here we're
talking about gram stains the cultures
aren't going to come back
for at least 24 hours perhaps earlier in
some cases of sepsis
we have to supplement this with other
laboratory tests
and imaging and really it's not until 24
to 48 hours where de-escalation may be
possible
based on the results of cultures and
susceptibility testing especially for
adding some of these
rapid tests to identify organisms
and to identify their susceptibilities
so really this results in a pretty
significant delay
as i mentioned there are also some
challenges with implementation and there
have been many studies that have failed
to show the desired impact on clinical
care and outcomes
so while we may have an ideal test if
it's not implemented in line with
workflow or the clinicians don't trust
the results of the test
then we've got a problem in terms of
actually improving outcomes
we all practice in complex healthcare
environments healthcare is dynamic
and so there are many changes ongoing on
a regular basis
and so the major gap is still often
integration
of the clinical microbiology and
clinical lab versus healthcare setting
workflows
and i'll touch on this a little bit
later but i think there's also often
at the development and implementation of
these tests the failure to consider
physician behavior and how we make
decisions
there are also in the emergency
department some particular challenges to
workflow
most of you who have been in emergency
department either as a patient with a
family member
or perhaps just walking through can see
how much crowding and boarding is going
on
while patients are waiting to be
admitted to the hospital
in the more urgent care areas there's a
lot of patient turnover
and therefore clinicians have to make
really quick decisions with limited
information
including access to diagnostic tests we
typically practice with a mix of
providers
in a shift-based scheduling format which
means there's a loss of continuity of
care and sometimes it's hard
to reach particular clinicians after
they've left their shift
and we also have to be comfortable with
a certain amount of diagnostic
uncertainty but the reality
is the diagnostic uncertainty even in
the emergency department
drives a lot of antibiotic prescribing
there's also the concern for health care
access
and poor outcomes no one wants to be the
subject
of a morbidity immortality report or
peer review
many of our patients as we are a safety
net for vulnerable populations
are not able to follow up for a variety
of reasons and so that's a concern also
and sometimes the thought is
if we give the patient antibiotic they
may do better
in reality we typically don't see the
adverse events that occur downstream
and then of course patient satisfaction
is a big driver
of antimicrobial prescribing
we've actually done some work in this
area looking at surveys
and in-depth interviews across eight
sites in the united states
with a variety of settings and really
these were the themes that we identified
that might drive some of this clinical
decision making around antibiotic use
so as i mentioned resource and
environmental factors that really
includes those issues of boarding but
also the availability of rapid
diagnostic tests
access and quality of care received
outside the emergency department
and believe it or not with this patient
satisfaction issue still being the major
concern even in emergency department
settings
the patient provider relationship does
drive a bit of this
there is also what i call clinical
inertia which is basically habit
is just doing what we've always done and
then in sites that had local
knowledge generation or quality
improvement initiatives around
antimicrobial prescribing
those settings the clinician seems to be
a little bit more comfortable
holding off on antibiotics when they
weren't necessary
etc
i think one of the main strategies
people always want to use is clinician
education so how does this work with
diagnostics
really i think educational strategies
while important
have limited effectiveness because it's
hard to reach all the different
clinicians that need to be involved
you really need to have some tailored
educational messaging
we've done multi-disciplinary grand
rounds engaged thought leaders from the
specialty or setting
but without ongoing oversight that's
really unlikely to lead to enduring
changes
and we know how overwhelmed we all are
now with zoom and email
there are also the perceptions of what
rapid diagnostic tests can do in the
emergency department
because we're such a risk-averse setting
i think most clinicians really prefer
high sensitivity and specificity
for all conditions but particularly for
high-risk conditions
also if we're thinking about turnaround
times
especially for point of care testing we
really like that to be less than 30
minutes for most conditions
perhaps a little bit less important for
patients being admitted to the hospital
and the test should be simple to
interpret
the other questions clinicians may ask
is if there's a benefit to testing
versus simple empiric treatment so
sometimes it's easier just to send the
patient out on an antibiotic
rather than send a test also sample prep
and training
can be an issue particularly for point
of care testing
and space is always a consideration as
we are always looking for more space in
the emergency department
testing strategies should fit into the
ed workflow and how we see patients
and then there's some major gaps where
we really don't have
great diagnostic tests including uti
and for other conditions simply focusing
on molecular again
not taking into account the host
response can also be a limitation
so let's talk a little bit about
calcitonin um so this is
a statement by work that was done by
schweitzel
back in 2018 but essentially from a
meta-analysis
for patients with varying types and
severity of acute respiratory tract
infection
using pcd to guide decisions about
antibiotics is associated with lower
rates of antibiotic exposure
antibiotic related adverse events and
mortality
so let's talk just a little bit from a
clinician's standpoint
what is pct so it's a simple blood test
that's specific for bacterial infection
and we find that in healthy people pct
concentrations tend to be very low
below 0.05 nanograms per milliliter
concentrations exceeding that threshold
can be interpreted as abnormal
and during severe bacterial infections
including sepsis those blood levels rise
very rapidly and typically there's no
elevation from viral infections
so here we have highly specific
induction these
this biomarker is produced in all
tissues and systemic infections
and you can see here the tissues that
produce calcitonin in healthy
individuals
and then on the right side you see the
tissues for example in sepsis
that produce that and so pct can detect
sources of production in systemic
bacterial infections so basically pct
ends up being produced and released into
circulation from the entire body
kinetics of pct are also interesting and
very relevant
for identifying bacterial infection
early so you see here
this is a graph showing time on the
x-axis
and on the y-axis you see the pct plasma
concentration
and typically what happens is pct will
rise about three to six hours after a
bacterial infection and peaks at about
12 to 24 hours
it has an approximate 24 hour half-life
and if the infection is adequately
treated those levels will start to come
down
so many institutions including my own
in the intensive care unit may use
procalcitonin
over time to de-escalate antibiotic
therapy
there are some non-bacterial causes of
procalcitonin elevation
particularly we have seen this in our
own setting as we have a burn unit
multiple trauma or severe burns or major
surgery
can lead to elevations prolonged
circulatory favor
uh failure excuse me and also newborns
under the age of two days
because they have a physiologic peak in
pct
there are also other non-bacterial
stimuli certain medications
or certain cytokines anti-lymphocyte
globulins
that lead to pro-inflammatory states
that can cause elevations in pct
certain cancers that you can see here
and then malaria and certain fungal
infections
also patients who have renal failure
particularly in the later stages
of ckd such as stage four and five and
end stage renal disease
will have slightly higher baselines
so how does one interpret pct here you
can see that in the healthy individual
again we expect
a very low level of pct and then as
that bacterial infection becomes local
and then further devolves into sepsis
you can see here that the
pct elevations will continue
so this helps determine both severity of
illness and adequacy of source control
here are some comparisons of available
clinical biomarkers we can think about
the simplest one that's available from
the cbc which is a white blood cell
count
it's not particularly specific in fact
in the emergency department
so many patients seem to have stress
responses and so we see our trauma
patients and other patients that will
have elevated white counts
without necessarily having an infection
but the sensitivity for inflammation can
be
pretty high so the advantages of a white
counter it's
simple and inexpensive the disadvantage
is it's not particularly sensitive it's
not specific for bacterial infection
and really is just a marker of
inflammation
what about crp or c-reactive protein
this is a little bit more specific for
bacterial infection
a little less sensitive than the white
blood cell count it too is inexpensive
and moderately specific
um but again it's got a slow induction
so the peak takes more than 24 hours and
there's no correlation with severity
we often test for lactate particularly
the united states
for patients with sepsis again really
not very specific or sensitive
again it's inexpensive it can be a
reliable marker of perfusion
and it can predict a bad outcome but
really
the patient needs to be in at least
occult sepsis for it to be elevated and
has very poor specificity
for bacterial infection that's not due
to that that doesn't lead to sepsis
so procalcitonin the advantages here are
much more specific for bacterial
infection
um it it is uh
has favorable kinetics again that rise
in half-life can correlate with severity
of illness
and it can help guide antibiotic use and
you can sort of monitor the
levels over time there is however a need
for education
there's a need for lab instrumentation
and it is more expensive than
white count crp and lactate
i showed this slide just to highlight
that clinicians are often very concerned
about sensitivity and specificity but
what we really want is a negative
predictive value
and of course that's going to depend on
the prevalence of the bacterial
infection in the population
that you're looking at however
procalcitonin levels can be used as a
rapid tool to rule out bacteremia
given the high number of false positive
blood cultures and the time it takes to
detect bacterial infection with a blood
culture
this is a study that was published in
jama in 2009 the pro house study
it was a multi-center non-inferiority
trial that was in
six tertiary care eds in switzerland and
they looked at approximately four
fourteen hundred patients um and what
they looked at was
um lower respiratory tract infections
they looked at antibiotic
with um use with a pct algorithm versus
the standard of care
and really had similar outcomes with no
change in adverse events and what they
were able to show
was a decreased duration of antibiotic
use in these patients
not insignificant from 8.7 to 5.7 days
here's another meta-analysis looking at
procalcitonin use
in 11 trials comprising 40 000
plus patients for lower respiratory
tract infection and the pct guided
patients compared to the
usual care had lower odds of antibiotic
initiation and a shorter mean antibiotic
use
there was no adverse impact on mortality
or length of stay
that's actually a good thing you want to
show that there's not an increase in
adverse events
from using these strategies
in the intensive care unit a
meta-analysis of rcts and adult sepsis
showed that pct guided patients
did have shorter antibiotic duration
compared with controls
about you know slightly less than a day
but not insignificant for icu patients
and pro-calcitin use again had no
adverse impact on mortality
finally there was a patient-level
randomized control trial
of hospitalized patients with lower
respiratory tract infection
from the ed in 14 us hospitals and i'm
going to show this study just to to show
that sometimes even though you have
a good test the failure of
implementation
may lead to less than desirable outcomes
so in this case
they randomized patients to usual care
versus clinical guidance for the role of
pct with an algorithm and then they
didn't find any significant differences
in antibiotic days between the two
groups
so why is that well a lot of the sites
were not
particularly comfortable with this
algorithm and so the education piece was
a challenge
there were also some challenges with
interpreting the algorithm and their
assays with different cutoffs
and the basis of calculating sensitivity
and specificity of pct levels as a
circuit marker for bacterial infection
really
um you know we need better diagnostic
tests for lower respiratory tract
infections
um and typically these patients were of
the sickest so they were
patients that were in the ed that had
community acquired pneumonia that were
being admitted to the hospital so the
clinician
already made the decision that this
patient needed an antibiotic and so in
this case
the pct may not have swayed them
in terms of delaying starting those
antibiotics
although the results of not having any
impact on duration were also a little
bit surprising
so why might this be perhaps some of you
have read this book thinking fast and
slow i think it really highlights how an
emergency clinician thinks
but really we have two distinct
cognitive systems we have a more
automatic system and a more reflective
system so people like to think that
clinicians are deliberate and rational
and reflective when they're making
clinical decisions
however in reality because we're humans
and we try to save our brain
space and energy a lot of decisions are
actually automatic so they're
uncontrolled effortless
based on associations they're quick and
they may also be experience based and
they're not conscious
so those are the ones that we really try
to target
to guide clinicians or nudge clinicians
to making better decisions
so what's the solution to this problem
of implementation
well at least in the research realm
implementation science based approaches
that are based on the principles of
behavioral economics can improve both
test ordering and clinical decision
making
so essentially engineering choices and
systems to give us the biggest bang for
the buck for new tests
some of this work can be done through
site-specific guidelines that
incorporate these biomarkers into
clinical practice guidelines or clinical
pathways that make it easier for
clinicians
to make decisions based on algorithms
there's an opportunity to tailor
recommendations based on individual
facility
antimicrobial susceptibility such as
from the antidiagram or formulary
there's an opportunity to provide
provider feedback
and comparisons and the role for
appropriate diagnostics can be
facilitated by clinical decision support
and informatics tools and we are having
some success in this area
at this time but what we really need is
a paradigm shift
we need novel diagnostics and algorithms
to aid in clinical decision making and
these need to
be incorporated into our workflows and
take into account
clinical decision making we also have a
debate about
early targeted versus empiric antibiotic
use
we really want all of us in the end to
improve patient outcomes and decrease
adverse events
and a nice benefit would also be the
downstream public health benefit of
decreased antimicrobial resistance in
the future
and preserving the antibiotics we have
so some future directions might include
more rapid
and cost effective diagnostic tools that
include the host response
such as biomarkers like pct
we really don't want to incorporate
tests that are going to require a lot of
training
and in the ed at least when we consider
point of care or even in laboratories
that have limited space
we really have to think about the
footprint of the instruments as well
so with that i will take any questions
and that is my email if anyone has any
interest in reaching out after this
presentation
thank you for your encounter
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
okay let's get started our first
question
is
how will pct be used during flu season
especially during the
current covid19 pandemic
so actually we're doing some research at
our institution around
um pct versus usual care with a clinical
pharmacist intervention to help guide
appropriate antiviral therapy
for patients with influenza and reduce
the inappropriate use
of antimicrobials um where they're not
indicated
i think you know with covid uh this has
really impacted
you know our testing strategies right
now the main thing that people are
focused on is the diagnosis of covid
um and you know supplemented perhaps by
imaging in our in our sicker patients
i think you know we find that pct is
typically very low
um in covid as in other viral infections
and so
for patients that are being admitted to
the hospital a lot of our hospitalists
and even ed clinicians are ordering tct
just as another adjunct to try to reduce
inappropriate antimicrobial therapy
okay thank you so much for that answer
larissa we have another question here
does clinical pharmacology support pct
as part of antibiotic stewardship
protocol
i'm trying to understand this does
pharmacy or
clinical pharmacology um
this question just says does clinical
pharmacy uh
support pct as a part of that antibiotic
stewardship
um oh okay yeah so i think you know
antimicrobial stewardship teams are
typically comprised of an infectious
diseases clinician
and an id pharmacist as well um i
believe many institutions have already
incorporated pct into their
antimicrobial stewardship strategies
i can say that at our institution for
adults
we do when a patient is suspected of
having sepsis do incorporate pct into
that algorithm
with a repeat pct per standard protocol
and those algorithms are provided to the
clinicians
for making decisions so at least at our
institution um
this has been found to be valuable and
is supported by
our antimicrobial stewardship team
including the pharmacist
and what spurred your hospital's
interest for pct
i think there had been a lot of research
ongoing with pct
particularly you know our um our chair
of pediatric emergency medicine who's
also the chair of
our emergency medicine group has done a
lot of work um looking at pct
in in several infants and that
was an impetus to get it into the ed
because he really wanted to use it
for those febrile infants under two
months of age
while that hasn't like made it yet into
the standard
protocols nationally i do think that it
can be
helpful in um helpful in guiding whether
that
the infant has a bacterial infection and
perhaps
eventually avoiding invasive tests like
lumbar puncture
um on our end you know we really wanted
to incorporate it
for patients with sepsis particularly as
some of our clinicians
on the wards and in the icu like to
follow
the level so that they can de-escalate
therapy and so
bringing that to the ed was useful but
in order for it to really impact our
decision making
we had to make it available in real time
so we now can get it under an hour
whereas previously it was not available
in that fashion
wow thank you so much for that answer
great we have another question
how has covid19 impacted your pct usage
especially the stewardship and c diff
prevention in long-term coveted
treatment
um so i don't have numbers for our
emergency department so i'm not sure i
think it actually probably though
anecdotally has increased it because
again patients with cobit 19
are often getting a pct um that's
ordered by the clinician
and then i i think in terms of our
standard algorithms i don't think it's
impacted that since we're using um
we've actually had some issues
um as many hospitals with non-ed
based sepsis so hospital onset sepsis
and we've
incorporated a team of nurse
practitioners
that are available to respond rapidly
whenever a patient
meets certain criteria for potential
sepsis
and that pct algorithm um is in their
workflow
and they're um they're following it
pretty closely so
i believe our institution though i
couldn't give you exact numbers that the
the pct utilization is going up
fantastic thank you larissa our next
question
how do you get an id on board or how do
you get id on board
uh when they feel like clinical judgment
is more valuable than yet another test
like pct
um i haven't had that experience
although i do know that some of our
infectious diseases colleagues have
varying opinions on the value of pct
i think a lot of it has to do with
implementation
um and i think the infectious diseases
clinicians particularly those involved
in antimicrobial stewardship
get frustrated at the fact that the
tests that are being ordered are not
actually being used in the way they were
intended so i think again that workflow
and implementation
and getting the clinicians to change
their behavior is the frustration on the
part of infectious diseases
but i will say that a test alone without
incorporating antimicrobial stewardship
or other strategies
is probably not going to lead to the
desired outcome so
i encourage everyone who's thinking
about implementing these biomarkers or
other
rapid diagnostic tests to think about
how the clinicians will use those
results
and really trying to drive practice
change so that you can actually see the
outcomes that you want
[Music]
makes sense thank you so much here we go
our next question
do you use the same cut off
procalcitonin value for infants as
adults
um so i believe the cutoffs may be
slightly different i don't have them up
in front of me but we have an algorithm
for adults and an algorithm for kids and
then of course
you know depending if it's an lrti or or
sepsis but those are included in
in the lab order so that we can we can
see those
um when interpreting the results
in fact there wasn't a lot of data i
should say when we first
started trying to use pct for instance
there wasn't a lot of data so
you know many many institutions when we
talked to our pediatric id colleagues
you know they had to come up with their
own algorithm based on other
institutions because
many many pediatric hospitals weren't
actually really using this so
it made it a little challenging when we
started this
and you stated pct utilization is an
educational intensive process
who is best who's the best driver of
bringing pct
to hospitals
so i think ultimately a lot of the
decision making
at least at our institution may be that
enter my critical stewardship
team so we're very fortunate here at uc
davis we have a very good relationship
between our stewardship team that
incorporates um
the laboratory and incorporates
microbiology as well
and so often when new tests are being
brought on it's really looked at by our
by our diagnostic committee um and then
we also have a test utilization
committee that that makes these
decisions so
it's really a multi-disciplinary
approach um these days that may not be
true for all community hospitals or
small hospitals
or critical access hospitals um in it is
not a one size fits all because in some
settings the clinicians drive
um the desire to bring on a new test and
in other cases
you know the lab sees the value um and
then still other cases you know it's
really a hospital administration
decision
thank you larissa our next question here
were days of antibiotics reduced
uh were days of antibiotics reduced use
based upon
delayed use of antibiotics or quicker
reduction of antibiotics
after initiation or both um in the
studies i presented um
well most of these are meta-analysis so
i think that there's some heterogeneity
in um in what's happening i mean from
from our perspective
um it's just uh it's it's stopping the
antibiotics earlier than you would have
i got it thank you uh next question have
you had
any resistance from clinicians in pct
uses
usage especially with antibiotic use
sure especially in the emergency
department i think
there is some concern particularly in
patients that you were thinking about
discharging home
that you might not want to get a pct
because you wouldn't want to see a high
result
and then you know it's sort of like you
don't want to see
what you don't think is real um and so i
think it's more appropriate for patients
that are being admitted to the hospital
where you can send
another test as recommended you know in
12 to 24 hours
i think most ed clinicians wouldn't be
using it for
patients that are being discharged
all right thank you so much again for
that answer
how do you apply pct to end-stage renal
disease um so i can't say that i have
enough experience i i typically don't
send pct in those
patients necessarily i can't say i have
personal experience
um with what to do with patients with ck
ckd i mean we certainly have that issue
for other
tests like troponin i think you know
perhaps trending over time might be one
way
that you can use that information
is a simple prick test sufficient to
test pct levels
um so i'm not familiar with the with the
point of care tests i don't believe
that they're available um here yet and
so ours is a is a blood draw
okay great that was simple um what value
does your algorithm provide for
um nicu um
i for nicu as a neonatal and neonatal
icu yes
yeah so so i um i believe that most of
what we're doing is in the picu not the
nicu
i'm not familiar with what our
institution is doing in the nicu i do
know that
they're using it in the picu um so not
not in neonates as much okay
and is there a way to incorporate
antibiotic resistance diagnosis along
with
host biomarkers for diagnosis no i
certainly think that that
is going to be a strategy of the future
so essentially you know combining
a an accurate
diagnosis of antimicrobial resistance or
the pathogens
likely through molecular techniques plus
a host biomarker
or other you know host biomarkers to
look at the immune response i think is
absolutely critical and that can give a
more complete picture
in the context of antimicrobial
stewardship than simply having
for example a diagnosis
of a particular organism or just having
the host response
do you see any added value of poc pct
assay in icu so we don't have any
experience again with the poc
essay i also um we don't have much in
the way of point of care in
in the icu setting so i can't i can't
really speak to that
i certainly think in the ed it could be
useful but again
we currently get our results typically
in about 45 minutes
and sometimes that's faster than our
nurses going and doing a poct test
believe it or not
and what type of molecule is pct what
induces
the release in bacterial inflammation
um so i'm gonna defer that question i
guess to the
to the um organizers um i can go back to
my slide
for a second and any questions can be
answered
at a later date you know via email or
yeah let me because i i need to
understand what what the question is and
that's more on the that's more on the
physiology of pcta and
clinician i'm not an expert in that
absolutely very understandable sometimes
these are complicated questions um
to answer on the on the fly ones let's
see
when you're not expecting do you see the
capability of constant pct
measurements to monitor progress using
either ir monitor
ir monitor or implantable monitor
well i know there's a lot of interest in
um you know in remote monitoring or in
uh
you know wearables right now i haven't
seen anything
looking at pct as a as a constant
as a constant marker looks like we have
one more question here um
cap for pct testing and the principle of
test that's all that's all the question
i'm not sure exactly what they mean but
maybe you do
the tat turn around time for pc question
i believe
is the is the first part of that
question so again like i said
um ideally we would like a turnaround
time of less than
45 30 to 45 minutes um but i think you
have to balance that with you know if
you have a poc t test how much
additional work is that and what are you
losing in terms of
sensitivity or specificity um so it
depends on the population i would say
um i don't know what the principle of
test
is either okay i wasn't sure either um
but that's uh that's the last question
that we have um
so thank you so much for your time today
larissa do you have any final comments
for our audience
um well i just think you know i'm very
pleased to have been here
i certainly think there's great promise
in
using biomarkers to help with patient
diagnosis
um i know there's a lot of exciting work
going on in this space right now
i do think it's important for
laboratorians to collaborate with
clinicians as they're thinking about
bringing on some of these
tests and also really that these tests
can't exist in a vacuum we really have
to think about workflow
both in the laboratory and in the
clinical setting um and really
incorporating it into a broader strategy
of antimicrobial stewardship and
improving patient outcomes
well we want to thank you again larissa
for your time today and for your
important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye